Assaf men they feel crushed by young and
therefore they say I must say different
for instance they take a concept of you
and they give it another name but it
means exactly the same thing just to be
original and creative and not just a
union or so on and that all shows that
they haven't understood that it is a
reality with which one is confronted and
that one's task is to confront oneself
with the same reality with which he has
confronted himself that's the same thing
and then if one does that oneself and if
one stays loyal to one's own work on
oneself one is constantly by one's own
shadow dreams etc reminded that one is
not young and hasn't gotten that far as
he got but the danger is inflation you
see it a bit the same thing in in some
power is always born during inflation
because he saw Christ and he did uses a
bit that he he wouldn't say he is Christ
but you know he has the great word now
to tell it's a very different fate than
Jung had I mean to come after him to
come after you is a very different fate
and one has to fully realize and have
the humility to also recognize this is
an exceptional man how in my idea the
he's of the size of Lao se or somebody
like that very rare that's a sort of man
which is born every two thousand years
in history and one cannot compare
oneself with him one has to try to learn
from him what one can and know that
there are enormous dimensions which we
don't understand yet which he understood
so one is really contained in him in his
work I mean it's in one way one is
contained in him inevitably but in
another way not because each time you
realize it something in yourself in you
only then it becomes yours I for
instance found out that when I read you
I can read his books 20 times and I
don't keep them in mind so to speak by
heart but when I do some creative work
results work and they read his books and
it ties in in what I am doing in my own
work then it clicks and then it stays
forever then it says if I had acquired
it I really got the point but only when
I have creatively worked out my own
approach by and that is really coming
back to what I said before getting out
of the Animas who who would simply quote
you and say now quite apart from cool
the Animus quoting you what do I feel
what do I see what have I experienced in
my life where am i what can I say not
because you says it but because I know
it myself too for my own reasons and
only that is valid the rest can be just
forgotten again oh he if people once in
the psychological club there was a big
crowd we got all pulled into it and
young afterwards told us I include
myself it told us you all behaved as if
you had never heard of Union psychology
is he complexes hidden the whole thing's
gone because it hasn't yet become really
yours he couldn't go if it had become
yours is that how you see the splits
that have happened in many of the
training groups partly detect and partly
it's also that most of the pupils of
young have only gotten one facet of you
they young had so many facets that he
also talked very differently to the
different people he gave them what they
could take or where they were hope and
he talked with one person about that and
with another person about something
quite different for instance I can say
he never talked to me because it never
came up between us about parapsychology
or very
really also very little about astrology
because I have no leaning in that
direction now I hear from other unions
the most amazing things he has told them
about these things I have just missed
out on that because I wasn't there when
I worked with him
so you see everybody got a facet
dicks instead of realizing that you had
so many facets and that the one the u
n-- they understand isn't the whole
young it's their yoga it's it's the
facet they they got so the splits are
eighty percent are necessary but the the
great sweets really come as you once
said about certain groups they have
given up union psychology and they have
taken to questi psychology